six one seven eight three zero 4750
we're gonna go to our next caller from
the seven one eight area code caller
from seven one eight who's this hi my
name is Ben doll from Queens New York
great what's going on so we have seen
help me need unhinge attack towards
North Korea and I was wondering is this
is Trump's narcissism the biggest threat
to national security is Trump's
narcissism the biggest threat to
national security in some way I mean if
we want to really try to
compartmentalize it in some way yes
right because what's a threat to
national security
destroying alliances with allies is a
threat to national security is it
Trump's narcissism that made him share
secrets that we got from our ally Israel
with Russians in the Oval Office to some
degree Trump probably wanted to come off
as the guy who I'm a big boy and they
tell me really secret stuff right so it
is narcissism in that way with with
North Korea Donald Trump believes that
he is the strongest and most powerful
and that's how he wants to appear and he
believes that he is better at figuring
situations out than anybody else so that
narcissism could make it so that he
makes really bad decisions with North
Korea I mean I think it's it's always
difficult to boil down the biggest
threat is something as simple as
narcissism but when we when it comes to
trumps personality I think that there's
a lot to narcissism as sort of like the
root of what could make a lot of bad
decisions take place yeah I mean I guess
you never really know until they react
right I mean if he comes out with all
this bombast and narcissism and makes
all these claims and statements yeah
he's trying to threaten these foreign
countries and they just back down then
we say that he won Yeah right exactly
yeah I think I think you're on to
something which is that as a as a
personality trait you know I think one
of the things that when it comes to
foreign policy made President Obama a
very sober arbiter was that he did not
seem to have that sort of pathological
narcissism that that pervades every
interpretation
by Donald Trump of what's going on
around the world so I think you're
probably onto something there all right
all right
thank you appreciate it